♪ ♪
>> Tucker: WITH EACH PASSING
DAY THE POSSIBILITY GROWS THAT
DACA WILL FORCE A SHUTDOWN OF
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT BECAUSE,
OF COURSE, LEGALIZING PEOPLE WHO
ARE HERE ILLEGALLY IS THE SINGLE
MOST IMPORTANT THING OUR
GOVERNMENT COULD DO.
IF PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYS AMNESTY
FOR DACA BENEFICIARIES AS A
POSSIBILITY BUT SHOULD BE TIED T
POSSIBILITY BUT SHOULD BE TIED O
LONG-TERM IMMIGRATION.
DEMOCRATS ARGUE THERE SHOULD BE
NO CONCESSIONS IN RETURN FOR
AMNESTY.
SOME ARE WILLING TO SHUTDOWN THE
GOVERNMENT DURING BUDGET
NEGOTIATIONS TO GET THEIR WAY.
CONGRESSMAN, THANKS FOR COMING
ON.
>> GOOD EVENING, TUCKER.
HAPPY NEW YEAR TO YOU.
AND ALL THE REST OF THE WORLD.
>> Tucker: HAPPY NEW YEAR!
ALREADY SET I'M WILLING TO
COMPROMISE.
AT THE PRESIDENT HAS SAID LOOK
I'M WILLING TO SUPPORT
LEGALIZATION AMNESTY FOR THESE
THEY HAVE TO ASSURE US THEY WILL
NOT BRING ALL OF THEIR RELATIVES
WITH THEM AND BEING ABLE TO
PREVENT PEOPLE IN THE FUTURE FOR
COMING WITH THEM LIKE BORDER
SECURITY LIKE A WALL.
WHY WOULD DEMOCRATS BE AGAINST
THAT?
>> CERTAINLY THE DEMOCRATS DO
NOT WANT THE GOVERNMENT TO SHUT
DOWN, PERIOD.
THAT'S OUR POSITION, FRANKLY WE
WERE NOT RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
SHUTDOWNS OF THE PAST.
HOWEVER, GOING FORWARD, WHAT ARE
WE TO DO?
WE DID -- WE DID, OR THE DID PUT
A 150 SOME ALIEN DOLLAR HOLE IN
THE MONEY THAT WE NEED TO FUND
ALL GOVERNMENT PROGRAMS FOR THE
NEXT YEAR.
IF THAT WAS THE TAX CUT THAT WE
JUST PASSED LAST DECEMBER.
SO WE START OFF WITH A VERY,
VERY DIFFICULT FINANCIAL
SITUATION IN WHICH $150 BILLION
THAT WE WERE COUNTING ON TO
SOLVE SOME OF THE FINANCIAL
TAX CUT.
>> Tucker: ACTUALLY WOULD
AGREE WITH YOU ON THAT.
THAT'S A KIND OF LEGITIMATE
ARGUMENT TO HAVE.
DO WE HAVE ENOUGH MONEY OR WE
GET THE MONEY, BUT WHY ARE WE
HAVING AN ARGUMENT ABOUT PEOPLE
WHO AREN'T EVEN CITIZENS?
I FEEL SORRY FOR THEM, BUT
THAT'S LIKE NUMBER 111 ON THE
LIST OF PRIORITIES FOR MOST
AMERICANS, WHY IS IT NUMBER ONE
FOR DEMOCRATS?
>> UNLESS YOU HAPPEN TO BE ONE
OF THE 800, OR 800,000 THAT ARE
DACA -- OF WHICH 160,000 HAVE
ACTUALLY GRADUATED FROM ONE OR
ACTUAL AMERICANS HERE AND THEIR
CONCERNS ARE GOING DOWN THE LIST
SO THE CONCERNS OF ILLEGAL
ALIENS AND TAKE THE TOP SPOT,
WHY?
>> THERE'S ALSO A HOST OF OTHER
PROBLEMS THAT ARE IN THAT
FUNDING QUESTION AND KEEPING THE
GOVERNMENT OPEN.
THE MILITARY WANTS MORE MONEY
AND FRANKLY NEEDS MORE MONEY.
WE ALSO NEED TO PROVIDE MONEY
FOR THE CHILDREN'S HEALTH
INSURANCE PROGRAMS AND ON AND
ON.
IF INFRASTRUCTURE, ANYBODY
MENTIONED THE TRILLION DOLLAR
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WHERE'S THE
MONEY FOR THAT?
IT MOSTLY DISAPPEARED IN THE TAX
CUT.
>> Tucker: I'M NOT DISAGREEING
WITH YOU.
CAN WE JUST GET PAST THE DACA
THING.
IF WE ARE SPENDING AN AWFUL LOT
OF TIME ON OTHER COUNTRY'S
WAITING FOR CONGRESS TO DO
SOMETHING SO WHY NOT JUST SAY,
LOOK, THAT'S FINE.
WE WILL BUILD A WALL, NOT WHY
NOT BUILD A WALL?
WHY NOT SNEAK IN A BRING YOUR
YOU SNEAK IN AND THEN YOUR
RELATIVES GET TO COME, WHY IS
THAT FAIR?
>> I THINK THAT THERE IS A
REASONABLE SOLUTION TO ALL OF
THIS.
THE DREAM ACT, WHICH HAS BEEN
AROUND FIVE YEARS NOW, IT DEALS
WITH MOST OF THAT ISSUE.
THE CHAIN MIGRATION ISSUE THAT
YOU TALKED ABOUT, CHAIN
IMMIGRATION ISSUE.
THAT NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED.
IT CAN BE A SERIOUS PROBLEM.
CERTAINLY THESE DACA STUDENTS,
OR DACA INDIVIDUALS ARE MORE
INTERESTED IN THEIR OWN
CIRCUMSTANCES, THE
ISSUE OF THEIR PARENTS AND
RELATIVES, YES, THAT SHOULD BE
DEALT WITH.
GOING BEYOND THAT, A WALL.
IT'S BEEN PRETTY WELL DETERMINED
THAT THERE ARE FAR BETTER WAYS
TO SPEND TENS OF BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS THAN TO BUILD A WALL.
THE COAST GUARD, FOR EXAMPLE,
NEEDS MONEY TO PATROL THE
OCEANS, WHICH HAPPENED TO BE THE
MAJOR WAY IN WHICH DRUGS ENTER
THE NATION.
GREEN CARDS, WHICH BECOME
CITIZENSHIP ON THE BASIS OF A
LOTTERY, THE DIVERSITY LOTTERY.
COUNTRY, IF WE JUST RANDOMLY
GIVE GREEN CARDS TO PEOPLE ON
THE BASIS OF CHANCE, A BINGO?
WHY DO WE HAVE THAT PROGRAM?
WHY CAN'T WE GET RID OF IT?
>> WELL, THERE CERTAINLY NEEDS
TO BE COMPREHENSIVE IMMIGRATION
REFORM.
AND THAT NEEDS TO BE ONE OF THE
PIECES OF THAT.
BORDER SECURITY ABSOLUTELY
ESSENTIAL.
HOW DO YOU SPEND THE MONEY FOR
BORDER SECURITY?
A WALL, IS THAT THE BEST WAY?
MANY OF US THINK THAT IS NOT THE
BEST WAY.
WE ALSO NEED TO DEAL WITH THE
AGRICULTURAL GUEST WORKER
PROGRAM, WHICH IS A MAJOR
PROBLEM HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
>> Tucker: I KNOW YOUR GROWERS
WANT CHEAP LABOR AS THEY CAN
GET.
I WOULD LIKE CHEAP LABOR AT MY
HOUSE TOO, BUT CAN WE JUST AGREE
THAT WE SHOULD STOP LETTING
PEOPLE IN RANDOMLY UNDER THE
DIVERSITY LOTTERY, AND IT'S NOT
FAIR TO LET ILLEGAL ALIENS BRING
ALL THE RELATIVES?
AND WE AGREE ON THOSE TWO
THINGS?
>> Tucker: THING YOU SHOULD